I was something that like when Wired
magazine came out in 1993 really loved
the magazine and loves so I mean if
someone who was always interested in
like science fiction and and new
technologies and I've been using the
internet since about nineteen
eighty-eight with like prodigy and other
sort of CompuServe and other dial-up
networking things and and even before
that doing some really basic like BBS
stuff with them you know a PC it was a
pc to from IBM so i mean i was familiar
with some that stuff but wasn't
necessarily like a script kiddie or a
hacker or anything like that it was
someone that liked kind of getting
involved and just sort of like the
promise of all that stuff and you know
it's like when wired came out it we kind
of felt like we were on the cusp of like
living in like a william gibson novel it
was like this like crazy world of
cyberspace and everything kind of seemed
like it was just about to explode and so
to be a part of that world in a way like
covering it documenting it and you know
I knew about all the stuff that was
going on in the.com world in nineteen in
the late 90s in cisco and it was a
chance to kind of actually participate
in it whether that rather than sit on
the sidelines and you know watching me
watch myself be slowly priced out of
apartments in the city i ended up
actually being offered a job either was
my choice I could work at the magazine
or I could work at red herring calm
which for some reason they had actually
splitting the two separate editorial
teams and rather than having to be
unified it was red herring calm did like
completely different work than the
magazine and sometimes they overlapped
and conflicted and things like that and
it's funny given you know where I ended
up that i would say water rather be with
the print magazine then on the online
but at the time I mean this was about
ten years ago that they're still there
were still difference in terms of
prestige to being involved with magazine
even a magazine that was covering the
technology industry so I chose to be
with magazine and ended up being a staff
writer for them and writing some really
great stories I mean it great I agree
are not necessarily like the stories
were that great but it's like it was an
opportunity to cover great things and to
go to South Africa to write about racism
and the in the technology industry there
or to go to Nepal and meet with the
Minister of Communications and talk
about
they're sort of you know steps towards
you know bringing broadband
communications to the country and when I
lost that job in 2001 I was laid off
along with about 40 other people in May
of 2001 it was definitely a big blow
because I'd really it been the first
time where I felt like I kind of had an
idea of what I was going to do with my
life I kind of realized well this is
something like I'm good at and this is
something that I can do I spent several
months try and fund and desperately
trying to find a new job trying to get
hot a job at Wired which was downsizing
mean they were firing people rather than
hiring people and I went through
actually a phase where i would actually
apply to magazines and then they would
go out of business the next day i
applied to one don't i don't know people
remember one magazine is very
short-lived sort of design magazine
based out of san francisco and well I
guess what 2000 2001 and I went to all
this trouble to put together a package
of Clips color photocopy it's been all
this money little money I had to like
put together this thing and I and I
borrowed someone's car and drove it over
the office and dropped it off and the
next day discovered that they had gone
out of business and this happened
several times were places i would write
freelance for or places i would apply
would all go out of business and George
magazine Steven Johnson's feed mag like
it happened about four times and you
start to really despair because you say
well I have to do something else with my
life I mean I you know this is not going
to work out and of course whenever the
bottom of recession it seems like it's
always going to be like that and when
you're 20 I think it was maybe 24 or so
no it's 26 so it seemed like you know
two years seemed like an eternity to try
to wait for something to turn around and
so I decided well if I'm going to be a
broke technology writer broke want to be
magazine writer I may as well do that in
New York where at least there are
magazines left rather than San Francisco
where it seems like the only game in
town is wired and they already decided
not to offer me a job and I was still
freelancing for them it's just I could
bed no full-time positions so I bought a
plane ticket decided to move on
September 11th of 2001
and of course did not make it there a
lot day